>> Harris: WE ARE GOING TO
PULL AWAY FOR JUST A MOMENT FROM
GOVERNOR ABBOTT OF THE GREAT
CEDAR TEXAS, BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH THE CHI
OF STAFF FOR THE VICE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS SUBJECT, STOCKS
REMAINING VOLATILE TODAY AFTER
THE DOW JONES FELL SHARPLY AGAIN
YESTERDAY, RALLYING JUST A BIT
TODAY.
CLOSING BELOW 20,000 YESTERDAY
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THREE
YEARS.
NEARLY WIPING OUT ALL OF THE
GAINS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
PRESIDENCY.
SHARES OF COMPANIES THAT ARE
AMERICA’S BACKBONE, LIKE HILTON,
FORD, AMERICAN AIRLINES, HAVE
BEEN IN FREE FALL IN RECENT
DAYS, AS YOU KNOW.
ALTHOUGH HILTON AT LEAST IS BACK
UP TODAY.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER RICK
MITCH McCONNELL SPOKE ABOUT
PHASE THREE OF US AND THOSE
PACKAGE EARLIER.
WATCH.
>> THIS IS A FORM OF EMERGENCY
TAX RELIEF THAT WE WANT TO PUSH
TO TAXPAYERS RIGHT AWAY.
IS NOT POLICY.
THIS IS NO ORDINARY TIME.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED HELP
AND THEY NEEDED FAST.
THIS WILL DELIVER IT.
>> Harris: MARC SHORT’S CHIEF
OF STAFF OR
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE.
SO GLAD FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
LET ME JUMP RIGHT IN.
>> HARRIS, THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
I THINK WHAT IS MOST IMPORTANT
IS IMMEDIATE RELIEF, AND
FINANCIAL RELIEF, TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE BELIEVE THAT IF YOU LOOK AT
WHAT’S HAPPENED IN CHINA AND
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IN
SOUTH KOREA, THESE OUTBREAKS
HAVE ABOUT AN 8-10-WEEK
LIFE SPAN
WORDS MOST INTENSE.
WE HAVE SEEN DATA AND SELF
CREATE EVEN MORE ENCOURAGING
THAN THAT.
IF WE ARE ABLE TO GET THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO ABIDE BY THE
GUIDANCE THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PUT FORWARD, WE THINK WE CAN
SHRINK THE DURATION OF THE
OUTBREAK AND LOWER THE SEVERITY
OF IT.
SO WE ARE REALLY TRYING TO FOCUS
ON THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY LOSING HOURLY WAGES,
THEIR SHORT-TERM JOBS.
WE DO THINK IN SOME CASES THAT
IS ACTUALLY TAX RELIEF AND
MAKING SURE THOSE SMALL BANKS
HAVE LIQUIDITY THEY NEED.
SO FOR THE SMALL FAMILY-OWNED
BUSINESSES THAT NEED CASH TO
CONTINUE PAYROLLS, THEY ARE ABLE
TO GET THAT FROM THOSE BANKS.
THAT’S REALLY A FOCUS, MAKING
SURE THE SMALL COMMUNITY BANKS
ARE LIQUIDATED.
BECAUSE WE THINK THE BIG BANKS
ARE IN GOOD SHAPE RIGHT NOW.
>> Harris: SO WILL PEOPLE GET
CHECKS?
>> I THINK THAT WILL BE PART OF
ONE OF THE MEASURES.
WHEN YOU COME TOGETHER ON
ANYTHING LIKE THIS, IS GOING TO
BE A BIPARTISAN ELEMENT THAT
BRINGS MULTIPLE DIFFERENT IDEAS
TOGETHER.
IT SEEMS THAT IS ONE THAT HAS A
LOT OF SUPPORT ON CAPITOL HILL.
>> Harris: IS THIS MOVING FAST
ENOUGH?
>> WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IS
SIGNIFICANT COOPERATION AMONG
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS.
WE ARE ENCOURAGED WITH THE PACE
THAT IT’S MOVING.
WE ARE ALSO, HARRIS, REALLY
ENCOURAGED BY THE COOPERATION WE
ARE SEEING FROM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IT’S NOT JUST INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE PRACTICING THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING, BUT BUSINESSES THAT
ARE ENCOURAGING IT AS WELL AS
CHURCHES AND FAITH COMMUNITIES.
WE THINK THE SPIRIT OF AMERICA
COMING TOGETHER IN THIS MOMENT
TO HELP DEFEAT THE VIRUS AT THIS
TIME IS AN ENCOURAGING SIGN.
AND WE DO THINK THAT CONGRESS IS
WORKING AT A RAPID PACE, AS
WELL.
>> Harris: I’M SURE VOTERS
WILL CONTINUE TO PUT PRESSURE ON
CONGRESS IF THEY THINK IT’S NOT
MOVING FAST ENOUGH.
YOU AND I HAVE KNOWN EACH OTHER
FOR A WHILE, SO I THINK THIS IS
RIGHT DOWN YOUR ALLEY.
WE WILL TRY SOMETHING NEW HERE.
WE’LL GIVE YOU ONE OF OF YOUR
QUESTIONS.
ARE YOU READY?
THIS IS ERICA T. FROM A RURAL
AREA.
SHE HAS THIS QUESTION.
>> MY TOWN OVER A LITTLE OVER
5,000 STILL SEES TRAVELERS
COMING THROUGH USING GAS
STATIONS, RESTAURANTS, AND
HOTELS.
WE HAVE ONE SMALL HOSPITAL WITH
25 BEDS AND ONE RESPIRATOR, AND
SEVERAL OUTLYING TOWNS WITH NO
SUCH FACILITIES.
THE CLOSEST MAJOR HOSPITAL IS
OVER AN HOUR AWAY.
MY QUESTION IS, WHAT CONTINGENCY
PLAN DOES THE GOVERNMENT HAVE
TWO SUPPORT RURAL AREAS?
>> Harris: THIS IS A TOUGH
ONE.
>> IT’S A GREAT QUESTION BY
ERICA.
I THINK WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES IS DEVELOP
PLANS, THEY COOPERATE WITH ALL
STATES.
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
THEIR OWN PLANS IN DEALING WITH
THESE SORTS OF PANDEMICS.
THAT’S WHY WE PROVIDE THE
GUIDELINES FOR THE STATES TO
IMPLEMENT.
I DO WANT ERICA TO BE
ENCOURAGED.
I THINK YOU HEARD SOME OF THE
DATA TODAY IN WHICH THERE ARE
THREE STATES THAT HAVE MORE THAN
50% OF THE CASES, AND THERE’S
REALLY TEN COUNTIES ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES THAT HAVE MORE
THAN 50% OF CASES ACROSS THE
WHOLE COUNTRY.
WE DON’T WANT TO SEE THAT
SPREAD, WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE
PUSHED FORWARD THOSE GUIDELINES
TO MAKE SURE WE CAN CONTAIN THIS
AS BEST AS POSSIBLE.
WE DO -- TYPICALLY THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE PROVIDED, THE PRESIDENT
BY DECLARING A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY SET UP FEMA TO HAVE AN
EMERGENCY OPERATION CENTER
ACTIVE IN ALL TEN REGIONS OF THE
COUNTRY SO GOVERNORS CAN WORK
WITH THOSE INDIVIDUAL REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATORS TO MAKE SURE THE
HOSPITALS HAVE THE EQUIPMENT
THEY NEED.
>> Harris: THAT’S IMPORTANT.
I KNOW THE DEFENSE PRODUCTION
ACT, TOO, THE PRESIDENT TALKED
ABOUT WHEN HE MIGHT TRIGGER SOME
THINGS.
WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT ONE
BREATHING APPARATUS FOR PEOPLE
ON THE MIC IN DURESS, THEY ONLY
HAVE ONE, THAT IS DISTURBING.
I WILL GIVE YOU A QUICK LAST
WORD.
>> WE HAVE A LOT OF INTERRATER
’S BEING DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
EVEN MORE, THESE RESPIRATOR
MASKS.
THE LEGISLATION WAS PUSHED WITH
THIS ADMINISTRATION’S HELP,
PROVIDING SOME LIABILITY
PROTECTION SO THE CONSTRUCTION
MASKS THAT TYPICALLY PRODUCERS
LIKE 3M WERE RELUCTANT TO SELL
TO HOSPITALS BECAUSE OF FEAR OF
LAWSUITS, WE MADE THAT EASIER.
SO THEY’VE ALREADY BEEN PRODUCED
AND THEY ARE NOW GETTING
DISTRIBUTED TO HOSPITALS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
>> Harris: THAT IS GOOD